well I think in in the early 60s
everyone had a folk guitar I grew up in
south Louisiana where music is is very
big Cajun music and so forth of course I
had nothing to do with that when I was
growing up but the the folk revolution
had taken place and so everybody had
folk Qatar's and we're learning Simon
and Garfunkel I just got a facebook
message from someone that I went to high
school with asking me if I remembered
the day we played at the school
auditorium where we played sounds of
silence and and I did remember that cuz
I could never play that B flat chord my
young hands at that point so yeah I
started then and then I was taking a
bath and had a transistor radio one
night and I saw her standing there came
on the radio and that kind of like
changed my life the other Beatles had
come to town and so then we threw away
our acoustics got electric guitar has
formed a band started playing around
town we had a couple of bands i might
there's my band and this other group we
kind of tended more towards the more
bluesy Rolling Stones kinds of stuff and
the other because the other band was
actually better and they could play all
the Beatles songs and seeing them we
couldn't actually achieve that we said
well we're going to be more authentic
we're gonna be bluesy and these other
guys going to be just beetle copies but
they were much better and I'm actually
in touch with the couple of the guys
from the other band again through
Facebook and things like that so yeah I
was said I always loved music I became a
disc jockey in the local town Eunice
Louisiana and I think my senior year in
high school and yes you know had a radio
show and i think friday nights and
sunday morning something like that and
then went off to college and had one
little brief band thing there which was
kind of prophetic in the sense that we
called herself cerebellum in the medulla
and i had at that point i was studying
marketing and business and had no
inkling
to being a scientist so it wasn't like I
was you know into that whole brain thing
at that point but at some point I did
switch gears I got a master's in
marketing and then while I was doing
that became interested in psychology and
started studying psychology and took a
course with a guy studying the brain and
just do all the other stuff where I
wasn't that into the marketing anyway
and the brain just seemed like an
amazing thing to study so I said that's
what I want to do but you know for the
rest of the most of my adult life I
didn't play guitar had it around and
didn't do much with it and at some point
I just picked it up again started taking
lessons and kind of getting more into it
and started picking around with Tyler
voc who's a biology professor at NYU and
we used to just get together and jam and
you know dream about having a band
someday and then in the fall of two
thousand six I got an invitation to give
a lecture at the secret science club in
Brooklyn it's in a held in a in the
basement of the union union hall in Park
Slope tiny little room and so I gave the
lecture and they said well we'll bring
some in they will get some entertainment
I said well I'll bring the entertainment
and so Tyler and I were planning to go
off and try this out and we recruited
Danielle Schiller who's a was a postdoc
you when you she played drums and she
played with us on a couple of occasions
at parties and stuff and she happened to
have a research assistant named nine
a'carly who played bass so you know we'd
practice a couple of times headed out to
Brooklyn and the amygdaloid were born at
that moment
both of our albums the songs are about
research their whole mind brain mental
disorder related related songs so in the
first album the kind of signature song
and kind of the band theme song is all
in the nut which is a tribute to the
amygdala cos amygdala is the almond in
your brain amygdala means almonds a
Greek word from so that was one we wrote
a song call an emotional brain which was
a take-off on my book the emotional
brain which is all about different kind
of mental disorders and facial
expressions of emotions things like that
we had this pretty good song called
mind-body problem which is a tribute to
de court except it's a all our songs
that love songs really so the mind-body
problem is my body wants you so but my
mind says no and so there's a lot of
inside of me is another decor pian type
song where it's about you can't see
inside of me it's a place only I can be
because you know de courts view of the
mind you know only you can know your own
mind and you can't know the mind of
anyone else directly and blah blah blah
so we had all and we also had a song
called memory pill which is about
erasing memory through drugs and so
forth and thats related to all this
research just talking about so then the
we did that but we that was sort of a
vanity press kind of album release we
paid for it ourselves and came out
really well and then we met some folks
who were interested in using music as a
therapeutic device and they came across
me and my research and music and they
decided that they wanted to do a CD with
with the band and they caught their
companies called knockout noise they're
a small record production company and so
over it and we talked about concepts and
so forth and over time we came to terms
and they produced the second CD took we
took a couple years to kind of do the
whole thing it was ready much long much
earlier than that but others we did a
lot of
post-production kind of cleaning up and
stuff and added some songs at the last
minute that we didn't have originally on
it and the original idea for that CD was
going to be to call it brainstorm but
then we decided to change it to
something else that had more of a kind
of serious scientific edge to it and so
it's called theory of my mind which is
based on the theory of mind idea which
is that in order for us to have social
interactions we have to have a theory of
what's in the other person's mind so we
can anticipate their behavior on the
basis of what we know about them and
their emotional responses and so forth
and I was in Cambridge England on
sabbatical last spring where Simon
baron-cohen is he's the main guy of
theory of mind in autism and so I
actually recorded Simon on base and one
of his colleagues Bhishma on tabla and
layered that on top of the recordings
that we have for theory of my mind it
sounds really good so it's theory of my
mind which is you know you don't
understand a love song you don't
understand me don't have a theory of my
mind blah blah blah so that's the the
lead song on the subtly Tom but it's a
title song of the CD we're really
fortunate on the CD to have rosanne Cash
singing two songs with me as my backup
vocalist not bad and she sings on mind
over matter which is my favorite song
and everyone who hears it so this it's
if we have a hit this is the one that
would be the hit it's just it's a really
nice kind of Airy song and that's one
almost sing for you in a few minutes
it's about love and loss and longing for
someone who's not there but you try to
use your mind to conquer the space and
time that separates you from that person
another song of a CD that Rozanne sings
on is and it's funny that she sings on
it because as I was writing it and kind
of getting the music out for him I was
sort of in my mind imagining sort of
channeling Johnny Cash and
it's a it's a song about a guy who's in
prison on death row and the reason I
wrote this song is I've gotten a number
of letters and emails from people on
death row asking for help in their
defense because the something called the
amygdala defense has emerged which is I
didn't do it my amygdala did and you
know unfortunately for them that I don't
think that the amygdala can actually
commit a crime I think that's possible
for crimes to be committed for you know
complex behaviors to be controlled
unconsciously but it's not the amygdala
that's during the amygdala is responding
to sudden threats and producing
automatic rapid responses mostly innate
hardwired responses so I don't think my
expertise can really help them but I do
think that there is an argument to be
made that you know a person can commit a
crime of passion that's outside of their
control because either they're under
tremendous stress or other factors that
cause them to do things that they
wouldn't ordinarily do now the bottom
line problem is how do you prove that in
this particular case that's what went on
or is that just a convenient thing to
say after the fact and so that's why I
try not to get involved in in legal
things because I don't think i could say
in one you know one way or another in
this particular case or in any case that
this is definitely what was going on but
I do think the court should take that
into account and be kind of hip to the
fact that the brain can do things
unconsciously and should weigh that as
part of the evidence so in crime of
passion the the guy catches his wife
with someone else and you know kills the
the other guy and so he's kind of
singing to the wife from prison saying
you know you're not worth what I'm going
through and all this stuff so it's not a
it's not oh I loved you so much and how
can you do this to me it's more about
you know why did I do this you're not
worth it
basically the reason I'm doing what I'm
doing now which is trying to integrate
the science and the music into kind of a
seamless whole it's because music is
such a powerful communicator I've
written books like the emotional brain
and synaptic South then translated into
dozens of languages each and you know
they've been really good sellers but I
think we can reach a different audience
with music and so I'm not saying I can
convey as much in a song as I can in a
book or even a book chapter but I might
be able to trigger an interesting spark
or an idea in someone that might be
prone to pick up a book so well what's
that with what is the mind-body problem
are and how do emotions come out of the
brain or kind of crime of passion really
be committed and to then you know pick
up a book or do some research on the
internet and just it's kind of like
raising awareness of the brain through
music and so I do think music is this is
really powerful but personally I've
never been inclined to study its I just
haven't been that's not what I've been
doing and enough people that are doing
it pretty well that I leave that to them
and so I just do i use the music as a
vehicle or tool to convey the scientific
information although i'm not studying it
myself